Ben Affleck completed 40 days of
treatment for alcohol abuse now he is
back in the public eye now and he is not
trying to hide his struggle it doesn't
really bother me to talk about
alcoholism and being an alcoholic it's a
part of my life it's something that I
deal with you know you have to work out
and you know I feel like I had a problem
and I really want to address it and I
think some some pride in that
Ben delivered that canted message of
sobriety and self-acceptance this
morning on today adding his family is
everything right now it's about yourself
your life your family I hope I'm a
pretty good dad I certainly try very
hard I'm lucky I got the they got a
great mom and she's she helps out a
great deal with you know making sure
that we co-parent as good a way as
possible but that doesn't mean they're
co-parenting choices always fly with the
kids last night at the premiere of Ben's
Netflix film triple frontier he told me
son Samuel just wasn't impressed with
Jin's How to Train Your Dragon Astrid
costume she wore it at his seventh
birthday party last week Sam was like
okay mom we already have an asterisk on
to all these lengths to put on the
costume you know find out that your
son's like we're just not that cool at
least Sam was a bit gentler when Ben
told him he's hanging up the Batman cape
for good how did Sam you'll take the
news cuz I knew he loved that you were
bad manners okay he kind of understands
like there's time for everything it was
my turn and now it's somebody else's
turn because he understands turn take I
love that
[Music]